GETTING WORD OUT OF ROW YAD THAT
SAUDI OFFICIALS ARE SAYING
THAT -- RIYADH, SAYING THAT
JAMAL KHASHOGGI, THE SAUDI
JOURNALIST, COLUMNIST FOR THE
"WASHINGTON POST," DID, IN FACT,
DIE N. INSIDE THE SAUDI
CONSULATE IN ISTANBUL, TURKIE.
THE SAUDIS' PROSECUTOR
ANNOUNCING THE ARREST OF 18
PEOPLE, ALL WITH SAUDIS IN THIS
CASE.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THE DEATH
OCCURRED AFTER A, QUOTE,
QUARREL, OR FIGHT, AT THE SAUDI
CONSULATE IN ISTANBUL.
JUST WIRE REPORTS, SARIOUS
WIRES, AFP, RUSERS, OTHERS,
WE'RE -- REUTERS, WE'RE WAITING
FOR AN OFFICIAL STATEMENT.
IT'S 1:00 IN THE MORNING IN
RIYADH.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET EXACTLY WHAT
IS BEING SAID AT THIS HOUR.
WE'RE HEADING BACK LIVE TO
ISTANBUL AND BRING BACK JOHN
ROBERTS FROM THE NORTH LAWN TO
SEE IF THERE'S WHITE HOUSE
REACTION TO THIS.
THIS COMING OBVIOUSLY AFTER THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TRAVELED TO
RIYADH, TO TALK TO THE SAUDIS ON
THIS AS WELL AS GOING TO TURKEY